all right everybody it is time for
drew's news your daily jump into that
good news ball pit and with me at the
desk football sensation and wfan radio
midday co-host tiki barber
there's only one way to say it
my trusty co-captain ross matthew hi
everybody hi
the awesome human actor and host of cash
at your door jason bish
i mean this couple is a dear friend of
our show she is an author with her debut
novel city of likes on the way jenny
mullen
all right should we hit the headlines
guys yes please all right let's do this
we've got some math that's gonna melt
your mind any 100 reports that a writer
named flora gill recently tweeted this
fact the main characters in season one
of golden girls are
actually
younger than the current characters on
and just like that whoa they're only
younger by about a year so we're talking
character ages not actor ages but both
shows are supposed to be about women in
their mid 50s and check out this side by
side i mean this is a real i think kind
of you know math aside society moment of
what we thought women in their 50s
looked like in the 1980s versus what we
think women in their 50s look like in
whatever that heck this time is called
absolutely
um
so i mean thoughts well it's just
fascinating how we depict them right
they golden girls they were they were
sort of gray hair they were all single
they're all living together and now
they're you know getting it in 2022. if
you're watching this show there's like
there is a difference or two in what the
golden girls were doing what these goals
are doing i will say blanche would fit
in with the and just like that girls
don't cross over there yeah i don't
think dorothea
it is crazy though but is it that people
just died sooner and that was like
you're 35 put a fork in you in the 80s
they're like sorry no no she has that
point turn it in the light
the lifespans were different and people
i think did think that 50s was old and
i'm going to be 47 and i'm sorry
i don't feel like i need to wear poly
pants well you could do it and have my
hair maybe not
think
do i want to think about sex with that
person at 50. back then you didn't want
to think about that now it's like now
you look at jennifer lopez you're like i
could think about that
now all i think about
is year old women
and it's clearly it's changed for men
too right i mean as a 23 year old i can
tell you
i'm putting you in a home next year i'm
putting on a home next year please do
i'm sending you off please it's time i
gotta retire you just remount the
package just confirm the kids are
staying with you
oh no okay they will 23. okay i'm going
to let that just sit there all right
but we are going to move on just for you
jason next we got the latest style trend
in home decor apartment therapy reports
it's all about something called royal
core what is that it's a term that
refers to any furnishing that have like
gilded golden opulent looks look at that
uh it's like something you might have
found on the set of the crown or
bridgerton
you know yeah
my style is less monarchy and more
mid-century modern so this is not for me
i won't be buying a golden gilded chair
anyone have that in their house
no not at all not for you and in fact
the second season of biggerton i i think
i'm boycotting no how dare you what no
why because
reg is not on it i get that and i saw
reg as me
really a good looking black dude
that guy yeah he's not there anymore i
mean come on you're not really going to
boycott it no i'm not but i just had to
say it just to get my
angst out i understand oh you speak for
so many people did you guys watch
bridger 10 well i sell myself as reg as
well
we did watch it but i couldn't get into
the sex scenes i felt like it was so
awkward
yeah the way he moved just it felt scary
say it
it just didn't feel yeah
it didn't feel real it didn't feel yeah
but it wasn't like it's a soap opera i
mean we don't have sex now at all so
i mean that way i mean that way
i mean that way we don't have sex that
way what about outlander outlander sex
scenes were good outlander yeah we
didn't watch out loud i don't see an
outlander either
maybe we all spice it up tonight yeah
outlander this evening yeah yeah and
then we can all circle back on how did
it go
i think
now i think that sex in movies were like
better in the 80s 70s and 80s body heat
yes come on you guys because that you
knew you were going to die soon
[Laughter]
because you were 40 and about to die
exactly tiki your story as if weddings
weren't expensive enough we've got
something new for brides and grooms to
pay for
the wall street journal reports couples
are hiring professional hashtag writers
to hashtag their special day the
classics like
happily ever after are long gone so
couples are paying anywhere between 15
to 125 dollars to get their perfectly
customized hashtag
jason jenny you guys hashtag your
wedding
we actually got married before the
iphone
wow so yeah but what do you think about
this though so no hashtag i think it
would have been difficult to like you
know pry another 125 bucks out of my dad
a professional
writer
but i like the concept i like the
concept yeah i guess
certain people are more like better set
up for it depending on your name right
what would our hashtag be though if we
oh god hashtag the biggs day
really good
so dumb you should get it your next
career is working for this company 125 a
pop huh yeah it's like cameo but for
hashtag i like the biggs day
is cute okay feels a little exclusionary
bye bye for american pie because like
your life was over after you married
can i just say though i just feel like
this i'm good i'm glad these people have
a business and good for them and uh-huh
but like hashtag you can do it yourself
right at home you don't need to hire
somebody to make yourself a hashtag
just get your bring your friends to
happy hour do what we're doing and come
up with we're trying to keep the economy
going man we need jobs man we need jobs
that's a job good for you guys i was
like
you're all right
[Music]